you see this is why I don't take naps
because when I nap and I check out for a
couple hours I wake up and I find out
that companies have been bought sold and
traded like magic cards
I see the big news hitting the Internet
that everybody is talking about is the
fact that Disney has bought out
Lucasfilm that's right George Lucas has
signed over Lucasfilm to Disney Disney
who as far as I'm concerned is
unofficially competing with Google for
world dominance to say it's it's crazy
and funny enough this news has gotten
mixed reactions I've seen comments
videos and reactions where people like
oh dude what Star Wars is gonna die it's
dead out of the worst decision ever it's
gonna die really die have you seen the
prequels that already happened
Star Wars fell from grace off of the
pedestal that it was on in the 80s over
ten years ago
so do I consider the fact that Disney
now owns Lucasfilm a good thing
unnecessarily I consider it a great
thing because ever watch a Star Wars
movie and just think to yourself you're
like it would be really cool to see how
this director would direct a Star Wars
movie or how this writer would write a
Star Wars movie now we live in a world
but that's not only a possibility it is
an inevitability
you know those trailers for Star Wars
The Old Republic you know over the Sith
just totally sack Khorasan you're like
the new Star Wars movie should totally
be like that now we live in a world
where it can be we now get to see new
Star Wars movies written and directed by
people other than George Lucas which was
part of the announcement it was
announced that we're going to get a new
Star Wars movie Star Wars Episode 7 in
2015 but there's a couple things about
that 2015 you can assume it's probably
gonna be a summer movie so summer 2015
which is about two and a half years from
now two and a half years from now we're
gonna get a brand new Star Wars movie
this wasn't just some decision they
decided yesterday you got to think the
cogs were turning this deal has been in
the works for quite some time years so
in terms of new writer and director for
a Star Wars movie bear with me on this I
don't know that this is actually gonna
happen but I'm just saying I'm gonna
throw it out in the universe see what
sticks if you look at the old Star Wars
movies in their glory days the
characters the dialogue between the
characters you know Han Solo and you
think to yourself who could make a Star
Wars movie like that let's all be honest
with ourselves I would love to see Joss
Whedon write and direct the new Star
Wars movie again now I know he's mr.
Avengers now so he's locked into doing
the Avengers do but that kind of stuff
happens all the time four directors are
doing one franchise and they're like
yeah I'm ducking out of this
this other thing I would love to see
what he does with the Avengers 2 I want
to see that but I also want to see what
he does with a Star Wars movie again if
I'm being realistic it's probably not
going to happen because the Avengers 2
is slated to come out in 2015 also but
I'm just saying if we want the best of
both worlds let Joss Whedon do the
Avengers to push back the new Star Wars
movie a couple years so he can do that
also that is called the fans winning
it's not that big a leap Joss Whedon
directed the Avengers which is Marvel
marvelous owned by Disney Star Wars is
owned by Lucasfilm which is now owned by
Disney you look at the leap it's like
one degree of separation I'm just saying
that could really happen and it makes me
smile gotta admit makes you kind of
smile too and it is said that Lucas is
gonna stay on as some sort of outside
consultant for these new Star Wars
movies which is a complete
jerk-off title outside consultants ultra
cup of coffee over there while the
adults make a movie thanks all I know is
this next Kingdom Hearts game you're
gonna see Darth Vader choking out Donald
Duck the next Kingdom Hearts game is
going to have Star Wars characters in it
if it doesn't someone's getting fired
and if I'm being completely honest and
sincere about this business decision
that George Lucas has made to sign over
Lucasfilm to Disney and give command of
Lucasfilm to someone else I gotta say I
have the utmost respect for that I've
given George Lucas a lot of over
the years Star Wars prequels I'm not the
biggest fan of so for him to go you know
what I'm not the right guy for the job
anymore it will have a better home here
let's see what you guys can do with it
that's a big deal for someone who built
that company to find it a new home
I'm sure the four point five Tilian
dollars he got from the deals pretty
good incentive also so props to George
Lucas I know he doesn't give a it's
not like he's sitting there in his
racecar bed at night going I really hope
Jeremy's saying nice things about me he
doesn't care I know this for a fact but
I'm just saying for the sake of saying
pretty much you look at any video I do
it's just me saying for the sake of
saying but it's fun to talk about
alright so Disney owning Lucasfilm and
everything Lucasfilm owns what do you
think about that and who would you like
to see write and direct the new Star
Wars movie that's supposedly coming out
in 2015 but will probably be pushed back
a couple years whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]